né
[Música]
a escala das relações
levamos a todos os lados e não são
resultados que importam mas a viagem
porque esses leva à cuba
estamos então engenheiro pedro afonso
mostrava bom jogo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quarta feira é um dia muito especial pra
mim eu não me enganei essa que hoje é
salva
eu estudei nesta casa há uns anos atrás
do tempo em que era uma casa só interna
tal como os internos nós entrávamos ao
domingo à noite saíamos a sexta à noite
ea quarta feira é o dia que vamos à casa
jantar com a família
creio que é mais ou menos o sentimento
comum quando nós somos mais jovens mais
pequenos que nós levaremos um sentimento
saudável da nossa família dos nossos
mais próximos depois os anos mais tarde
ficamos é com soldados voltar próximo
dos nossos camaradas no fim das férias
mas isso treinou nos as nossas emoções
para nós aprendermos a sentir gratidão
pela presença do outro pela presença dos
que mais gostamos
na altura e havia só uma cabine
telefónica alinhou pelo gabinete oficial
de água no corpo alunos
nós ligamos pra casa não viu a sap redes
sociais não é móvel
sou hoje
se fosse possível eu fico muito
satisfeito de saber sobretudo os mais
jovens não podem usar o telemóvel
eu trabalho em tecnologias de informação
e comunicação os meus filhos não têm
telemóvel só deixa o mundo digital
porque nós temos que nos permitir sentir
soldava esse tributo nosso tão português
para também aprendemos a sentegrity dão
pela presença dos que mais gostamos uma
centralização de vida profissional que
foi há cerca de um ano atrás
houve uma pessoa que muito valoriza e
muito tempo disse uma coisa que foi esta
pedro muitos parabéns mas sabe que os
relacionamentos são mais importantes que
as realizações e eu sendo mundo digital
podia vir aqui falar vos daí o 'the big
data tecnologia digital
mas eu escolhi este tema dos
relacionamentos propositadamente neste
tema que a escada da vida
nós passamos uma grande parte da vida a
subir outras vezes temos outras vezes -
o direito à vida não é sempre igual
há uma coisa que tenho é nossa meta é
que as pessoas que nós apanhamos quando
temos as filhas casa são exatamente as
mesmas que nós vamos apanhar quando
estamos a dizer
são as mesmas pessoas e isso é uma coisa
que clarificar em relacionamentos e
realizações quando falamos realizações
falamos do sucesso das nossas conquistas
e às vezes quando passamos a vida a
subir pensamos que somos heróis somos
muito bons e ficamos um carinho grande
por é para isso que os relacionamentos
erva é para nos recuperarmos e
relacionamentos e realizações tal
serviço de uma outra coisa de uma causa
maior
nós aprendemos aqui nesta casa que é
servir o outro fazendo jus a um dos
lemas deste nosso colégio que é servir
ainda nesse tema dos relacionamentos
faça uma viagem mental por um
procedimento especial ainda minha vida
que é o relacionamento com meu pai ele é
a pessoa que materializa isto os
relacionamentos são mais importantes que
as realizações é uma pessoa com grande
sentido a educação é uma pessoa que
existe para servir o outro para servir a
família sempre ao serviço da família e
hoje eu como pai em uma espécie de
conflito
eu tenho três filhos de 13 e 20 meses eo
conflito é este será que eu sou tão bom
para os meus filhos
como meu pai foi é pra mim ainda hoje
com 79 anos
e olha que eu tenho muito mais maior e
eu e os meus filhos temos muito mais
informação
temos muito mas é essa é a tecnologia do
que o meu pai tivemos e perguntou vocês
que atestou a falar uns com os outros
alguns perguntam vocês porque eu estou
traseiro sistema para que hoje é que as
nossas pessoas que nós lideramos e
alguns de vocês são graduados e
graduados as pessoas que nós lideramos
são pessoas como nós
são pessoas que precisam desligar
emocionalmente e já agora as pessoas
recebem o produto do nosso trabalho o
resultado do nosso trabalho também são
pessoas como nós e essas técnicas
avaliou na vida
porque nós estamos a falar de
conectividade nos ligarmos os outros
pelos telefones e pelas redes sociais
nós estamos só a falar do ferramentas e
quando nós estamos a falar ligações
emocionais
nós estamos a falar de emoções humanas
estamos a falar de desenvolvimento
humano
os relacionamentos são mais importantes
que as realizações e pensava eu que era
um tema que só eu que andava a estudar
ele mesmo estaria estudando há algum
tempo e finalmente não tremeu e não é de
agora
a universidade harvard
alguém sabe o que está a dar valor a
aplicar nos estados unidos estão a
economia tem o mais antigo estudo vivo
de todas as universidades do mundo é um
estudo que dura há 77 anos foi tão bem
as 37 anos
há pessoas neste estudo com 90 anos e
dava a segunda e terceira gerações das
famílias dessas pessoas ainda neste
estudo
o objetivo do estudo é este o que torna
a vida das pessoas mais saudável e mais
leis ea conclusão do estudo esta é que
independentemente de as pessoas serem
mais ricas e mais pobres das pessoas
serem mais inteligente ou menos
inteligente das pessoas serem mais
famosas o mais conhecidas
desengane-se quem pensa que há dinheiro
e prestígio quanto na vida o que torna a
vida das pessoas mais saudável e mais
feliz é qualidade dos seus
relacionamentos é qualidade dos seus
relacionamentos
agora creio que estamos de acordo que é
qualidade do ensino - depende do valor
base também nós aprendemos aqui na nossa
casa que é o valor confiança
o valor confiança
e aqui entra menos luz ninguém novo
nós forjamos o valor começa nesta casa
desterrado de que o que é mesmo
importante da escada da vida é quando
mudamos de grau
garantimos que a nossa reputação do
grupo anterior estava em nós passamos a
vida a trabalhar para construir nossa
reputação e podemos problema com o lugar
errado
e outra coisa muito importante é que
devemos sempre feedback a questão à
nossa volta sobre a nossa reputação
muitas vezes nós não somos capazes nos
julgarmos a nossa própria felicidade que
está à nossa volta e estamos a confiança
é muito importante para qualquer
profissão de vocês vai manter no futuro
nós nos séculos dias fizemos essa
pergunta
a consultora caption esqueça o nome da
consultora não é muito importante o que
é importante é que nós fomos perguntar o
que as pessoas achavam do nosso setor na
área das tecnologias ea conclusão deste
estudo já tem cerca de dois anos está
atualizado esta é que banca a política
tem hoje um baixo nível de confiança das
pessoas na opinião pública mas também
não é novidade para ninguém que o setor
do digital das tecnologias da informação
e comunicação têm hoje um pique
confiança das pessoas da opinião pública
quer dizer que as pessoas confiam
naquilo que nós dizemos mas confio
naquilo que nós dizemos e para portugal
esse tema tem um significado ainda maior
nós somos hoje não dá notícias que
portugal está na moda
então em qualquer profissão que nós
desenvolvemos nosso país da nossa pátria
este conceito quem pouco se desenvolve o
conceito de pátria em qualquer profissão
nós fizemos temos a responsabilidade de
fazer melhor e mais confiança implica
mais responsabilidade e mais confiança
implica muitas vezes decisões da nossa
vida muito difíceis e quando nós temos
visto uma empresa privada que tem como
objetivo o lucro financeiro significa o
que significa que mais confiança gerar
mais confiança implica decisões negócio
muito difíceis mas ainda há quem nos
inspira ainda apenas um espelho eu
trabalho numa das 200 maiores empresas
do mundo em março do ano passado o
presidente global da nossa companhia fez
um comunicado interno comunicado externo
proibiria no 102 países onde estamos
presentes também nos media em portugal e
esse comunicado era sobre um projeto
supostamente estratégia para o mundo
trata se do muro dos estados unidos como
méxico já todos ouvimos falar desse
projeto
o nosso grupo pela dimensão que tem e
foi naturalmente convidado a participar
ea fazer uma proposta para isto
e esse comunicado foi muito claro sobre
aquilo que nós pensamos neste projecto
pensem que estamos há muitos anos a
tentar entrar nos estados unidos pela
porta da frente
este é um bom caminho mas a nossa
resposta fazer um projeto desse tipo foi
exatamente esta coisa são as palavras do
senhor
a hashtag quinto aqui um tutorial time
campeão gaúcha o técnico alex ferguson
do united states
o hiper finotti to go nota do visual
agora imaginem o orgulho que todos os
colaboradores do grupo tiveram quase 200
mil pessoas no mundo inteiro sobre uma
decisão destas foi brutal foi brutal e
pra mim se dúvidas ainda mais uma coisa
é que entre os resultados de hoje entre
os resultados e os valores de sempre
seguimos sempre tivemos sempre um dilema
é que nós neste momento não temos carlos
nós fizemos sete pontos precisamos de
ligações emocionais entre as pessoas e
as organizações empresas escolas entre
as organizações e os seus clientes quer
utilizá entre culturas entre gerações
nós vemos isso no novo digital todo
ligado com muito otimismo com muitas
oportunidades
qualquer coisa como isto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e assim nós vemos o futuro
em junho do ano passado eu fui à europa
parque com minha família
pensava que a europa perca
além desta partida e funções de negócio
a participação de alguns parceiros nem
as partições mito europa para um grande
partido funções na manhã foi com minha
família eu tenho três filhos como os des
têm levantado a voz e dados
entramos no parque fomos no final de
semana a entrada do parque o habitual
ruído do merchandising papel de
guararapes também posso fome
ficamos aqui o quarto os muse é só a
papel já não existe
lá encontrará na postura anti crise o
iraque o dia e fomos restaurante não
gostaram
fui digital todo digital hora do almoço
lá fomos a um restaurante
entramos num ecrã grande na entrada e
dizia que nós colocássemos o nosso nome
fomos conduzidos pelo ecrã uma mesa
quando nos sentarmos e em cada lugar da
mesa havia um tabu na nossa frente nesse
tablet
nós fazemos o pedido da comida queremos
comer pra almoçar e depois através de um
corredor aéreo é comida vinha da cozinha
diretamente para o nosso lugar
nenhuma interação com ninguém 0
interação com pessoas humildes até nem
nunca perdem água acabaram por ser mais
uma passagem não deixava pessoas né
tenho mais mágoa por ver aqui ouvi lá no
court é chegar no fim da refeição
saímos pagamos não interagente com
ninguém e passávamos horas quando nós já
estávamos a passar no parlamento
eu e minha mulher queremos a ficha é que
em vez daquele almoço ser um momento de
interação entre a família
foi um momento de interação entre a
família ea tecnologia
eu enquanto profissional das tecnologias
fizeram uma grande tomada de consciência
é que nós temos que fazer tecnologia com
o propósito ligar mais emocionalmente as
pessoas e em comprar qualquer profissão
que vocês vão desempenhar no futuro em
qualquer profissional que nós tenhamos
hoje nós temos que fazer o nosso
trabalho com o propósito lugar mais
emocionalmente as pessoas e eu até
costumo dizer aos meus colegas que
enquanto setor
nós temos o dever temos a
responsabilidade de pensar nos ver o
mundo que estamos a construir e nós
enquanto menos de luxo meninos e meninas
da luz
nós fomos e somos formados nessa grande
casa para liderarmos no mundo que
tucanos e eu enquanto nem 12 enquanto
profissional que trabalha no setor que
está no centro da transformação de todas
as profissões que vocês possam imaginar
o professor
hoje fala-se do médico 4.0 o soldado do
futuro o piloto aviador que vai conduzir
drogas
everton chutar aviões desculpar
eu sinto uma responsabilidade ainda
maior de servir em qualquer coisa que
faça no meu setor e que estava a pensar
se eles pra vocês hoje no presente na
aplicação do vosso estudo e no futuro em
qualquer profissão omissão vida que vai
manter porque mais importante do que a
conectividade mais importante que os
lados nas redes sociais o que é mesmo
mesmo portanto o que é mesmo importante
são as relações de qualidade na escada
da vida
e como eu acredito que os gols
treinamentos são mais importantes que as
realizações
eu posso ter muitos conflitos pode ter
muitos dilemas possa ter muitas dúvidas
mas há uma certeza que eu tenho é que
como nos 12 com português
vamos transformar o nosso mundo com
imaginação e com o coração
[Música]
fantástico fazer este número nesta nossa
grande casa e lembra os relacionamentos
são mais importantes que as realizações
com grandes aqui atrás até cento
[Música]
[Aplausos]